I love your dress I love our green
Ensemble we I know I was like you are
your green it is weird though it has
like random yellow that you think is an
accident it's not okay um how are you
this holiday season you love Christmas
good I do I I love the holiday so much
me too it makes me so happy do you all
have like you have a big family right I
do have a huge family yeah do you have
any tradition we have a lot of
traditions we wear matching onesies I
get onesies for my entire family we
usually start watching the Harry Potters
and we just watch every single one
that's me and my kid you just explained
my house with me and my kids really yes
oh my gosh I thought I was crazy no I
literally put them like I I think when
they were younger I was like this might
be too soon for Lord Voldemort because
it's a little scary you know the
Dementors all of it and then nope they
didn't care and yeah we watch it every
yeah I love a onesie thing will everyone
in your family get in it oh yeah I forc
them all I love it yeah I even have it
for our dogs of course you can't they're
family you can't forget them those are
four-legged family members I this is my
favorite thing I've heard about you
you're so talented and so beautiful and
gifted but I love this story I heard
that the house that you grew up in which
was like many generations of your family
y'all ended up losing that house and
then you bought it back yeah so it was
my great grandma's house yeah I love
thank
you how did y' lose it what happened
well no so it was my my grandma my great
grandma had this beautiful house um it's
like a two-bedroom cute house that they
lived in my grandma was born in it my
mom was born in it and then as the kids
got older they built on the property
another home and when my great grandpa
passed away and my great grandmother got
old they just couldn't afford to keep it
anymore yeah they upkeep it and yeah
it's a lot and last year I called up the
owners and I said I want to buy my great
grandma's house back that's
amazing I think that's so cool man yeah
and it's really cool too um my my grandy
still lives in the house next door so
I'm neighbors with my grandy you're like
a Hallmark movie like you're like a do
you get into those at Christmas time I
do you do
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home